SOWMYA SUBRAMANIAN: All right.
So everyone ready for
our afternoon session?
[AUDIENCE CHEERS WEAKLY]
SOWMYA SUBRAMANIAN:
It's not loud enough.
I know there's more energy.
[AUDIENCE CHEERS LOUDER]
SOWMYA SUBRAMANIAN: Good.
OK.
Before we get started, I seem
to be always pointing out
where the restrooms are,
but that's my job as the MC.
The restrooms are out the door
and down the hall, that way.
And I think there
are signs there.
And there will be
Google volunteers
who can help escort
you if you need help.
And we will be taking a
break between each session,
each speaker, in this afternoon.
So if you do want to switch
to the other track, that
would be the time to do it.
And the other one is also
happening down the hall.
And one of the
Google volunteers can
help you get to that other room.
So our first speaker is
the Head of Localization
and International
Product at Jawbone.
Her focus areas are
product marketing,
business development, user
experience, technical account
management, and ad operations.
Laura was named one of the 40
Most Powerful Women in 2013
by "Forbes Mexico."
And was also recognized
by the Department
of State and Secretary
of State Hillary
Clinton for her involvement in
the Tech Woman Program, where
she was only female leader from
Twitter to participate in 2012.
Please join me in
welcoming Laura.
[AUDIENCE APPLAUSE AND CHEERING]
LAURA GOMEZ: Hi, everyone.
Can you hear me?
Yes?
Great.
I just want to take
a sort of a poll of--
and maybe you can
raise your hand.
How many students
do we have in here?
Great.
Other-- in the back.
Hi, student.
People who work in
the industry here?
I'm guessing at Google?
Great.
Google representing the front.
Other tech companies?
Facebook, Twitter, LinkedIn.
Who does not work in
sort of what I've called.
I think I was talking to a
woman here, a young lady,
that she actually
works in health care.
Are there other
industries-- there you
are-- that are not represented
or I have not said?
AUDIENCE: Startups.
LAURA GOMEZ: Startups.
Education?
AUDIENCE: NASA.
LAURA GOMEZ: NASA.
Great.
So I'm very honored to be here
on International Women's Day,
speaking in front of all of you.
Also, let's take a moment
to realize how honored
and how privileged we
are to actually be here.
On this day, there is many
women that don't have access
to either attending
these sessions
or around the world that
actually don't have access
to technology.
So let's make sure that
we understand where we are
and how privileged
we are to actually
be in an area in Silicon
Valley, and where
we're meeting and being next
to all these amazing women
that I've met so far.
I'm going to just speak on
behalf of just being a woman.
Zora Neale Hurston, does
anyone know who this author is?
OK.
I read a book in
high school that
said that the black woman
is the mule of the world.
Saying that the white male
oppresses the black male,
and the black male then
turns around and immediately
oppresses-- and this talks
about gender and race.
And I'm not here to really
talk about gender and race.
But as you know, my
presenter just said,
really it's those unconscious
bias that we don't speak of.
My accent, how I look
like, where I was born,
what is my background.
In Silicon Valley,
we tend to number
ourselves by what employee or
what team we're working on.
And it's just really being
honest about our privileges
that we have being here.
So I'm going to talk about
my resistance to technology
and being in the tech field.
And how I ended up here,
and now how I feel about it.
And I want to go over
who am I. Why am I
speaking in front of you,
besides my LinkedIn bio
or my Twitter
profile or something
that you can Google on me.
But who am I?
I'm really going to go
deep into giving you
sort of a look at Laura.
Not just the brand or image
of me or the idea of me,
but really who am I.
And searching for a job
after college for
all those students
and then finding a career.
And also the loyalty
that men and women
have shown for me
throughout my whole career,
throughout my whole life.
And then of course,
the next steps and what
I want to do as far as taking
everything that I've learned.
OK.
Here is some background.
Throughout my travels,
I've traveled a lot,
I was actually very lucky
and either fortunate or lucky
to be at the right time
at the right place.
I was in Brazil at one
time, and I ended up
going to an after party with
a very famous soccer player
while traveling in Brazil.
I would do something else and
then come home three days later
and my roommate was
like, where were you?
And I was like, well, then I
met this famous samba player.
And then we went and partied
with these other people.
And it just ended
up that she said,
you were born with your
butt to the moon, Laura.
And I couldn't understand what
that saying was in Portuguese.
I was learning, and I had to
ask people what that meant.
And they said, that
you were born lucky.
And I do think I was born lucky.
But I also feel
like the moon has
come to me because I
have worked hard for it
and because I have sought the
right opportunities as well.
So obviously when you see the
moon when you-- one day I'll
write a book and it'll be
called "Ass to the Moon"
because I think it'll be
titled exactly not just
because I'm lucky or fortunate.
But I was lucky,
and you'll see where
my luck came in, but with my
hard work and opportunities.
That's me as a child,
three years old.
You can follow me on Twitter.
My user name is @Laura.
I can go into detail why
I have that username,
but you can figure it out it.
I was an early Twitter employee.
So that's how I got it.
That's my sister next to me.
I was born in Leon,
Guanajuato, Mexico,
which is central Mexico.
I thought it was a happy
childhood up until I
came to United States, and
I compared that childhood
to the childhood that people
had here and the accessibility
and abundance that the
United States brought
in comparison to my childhood.
But I grew up happy.
And my great-grandma's
ranch every summer,
running through the cornfields.
Everything you could possibly
think of with my sisters.
Around the age of eight or
nine, and I don't really
disclose this-- my
mom was a young mom.
My mom had me at 20.
So when she was only
27, 28, she got cancer.
And so she was here
in the United States
visiting family
member, and so she
decided to actually go ahead
and get treatment here.
Luckily, our family all
lived in the Bay Area.
So at the age of around
10-- that's my hometown
It's just for everyone
to know Guanajuato.
It's really beautiful.
You should visit.
Tell me if you have any tips.
I'll give you a lot of tips.
It's colonial, and
it was a happy place
to actually grow up.
I think that's the first
picture in the first apartment
that we took after
we came from Mexico.
Obviously, my
brother looks scared.
My sister looks confused.
But then, my older
sister and I look happy,
because we knew we were now
here in el norte, the north.
You know, this place that
I remember my cousins
going to Mexico and telling me
that my eyes would turn blue
and my hair would
turn blonde once I
migrated to the United States.
And I was like, I
like my brown hair.
I like my brown eyes.
And as an immigrant, I
learned-- and I promised her
I wouldn't cry-- but
I learned English.
Who is here?
My fifth grade teacher.
On her 64th birthday she's here.
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERING]
LAURA GOMEZ: She's actually on
the State Board of Technology
and Education, so everything
comes full circle.
Ms. Paradise, that's her name.
So I was like,
this is the reason
that the United States
is so successful.
All the teachers
have amazing names.
The teacher after her
was called Ms Bright.
I was just like, United States.
It's amazing.
Later did I learn
that not all teachers
had really amazing names.
But Ms Paradise, she
was just telling me
that she knew how adept I was
to math, in spite of my language
barriers.
I convinced her.
I said, let me
stay in your class.
I know I don't speak
a lot of English,
but I will at the
end of the year.
And I think she still
has this essay where
I wrote a whole
essay, and then there
was a little heart
with a Mexican flag
and the US flag at the end.
But she believed in
me, and she believed
that-- I knew that
at fifth grade,
if I stayed in ESL, or English
as a second language, course
then in sixth grade
that would happen--
that in the middle
school, I would still
be tracked into that track.
And then in high
school, I would not
have access to the AP courses.
I didn't know that
when I was 10,
but I knew that I wanted
to learn English--
so that I could insult my
cousins, but also get ahead.
And now I see the
decisions that were made.
And so I discuss this, and I
call it horizontal loyalty.
From the time you're born to
the time you actually move on,
all of that-- your
faces when you're young
or when you're studying.
Or when you choose a career
or when you personally
choose marriage and children.
And move on and then retire.
There will be people
that will follow you
throughout the whole horizontal
journey of your life,
and that's called
horizontal loyalty.
And I think I'm here through
this horizontal loyalty.
And I know that I
will be supported,
finding that community, as
the speaker said this morning,
finding that community of
people that support you
through your path of life.
At 17, although I was
keen to math and science,
I didn't really have
a lot of educators,
besides Ms Paradise, that
really pushed me to it.
I was natural, but I
also got good grades.
I learned English, and I even--
my prom date at that time,
I got a better AP score, an
AP English score, than he did.
I got a five; he got a two.
And I was like,
you were born here.
What happened?
I learned English
four years ago.
So I got my first internship
at Hewlett Packard.
I grew up.
My mom was a nanny to a
CEO of a big tech firm.
And for me at that time,
the late '90s was just,
this is tech?
This is software?
I had an internship, at 17,
software technology department,
right before I entered Berkeley.
I got a full ride to Berkeley
by an engineering company
called [? Raychem, ?] now Tyco
Electronics, at that time.
And I was on my
track to actually
be in tech and
engineering and science.
And I resisted.
I got that internship.
I said, I don't
want to work here.
It wasn't something
that I felt--
that was the beginning
of when I decided
not to be in engineering.
And I went to UC Berkeley.
Who here is a Cal Bear?
I went to the dean.
I'd be like, I don't think
I want to be an engineer.
They were like, OK.
Choose another thing.
There wasn't a lot
of support for me
to maintain on that track.
That's the same year
that Google was born.
And now that you think
about it, I'm here 15,
what 17 years later?
Yes?
If I would have chosen a
track, where would I have been?
But obviously I didn't.
I chose economics development
studies, languages.
I was keen to
languages early on.
And now professionally,
that's what I do.
Localization's all about
languages, and international.
So by the time I
reached college,
I was learning my third language
in less than eight years.
So I had learned English.
Then I took French
in high school,
then I took
Portuguese in college.
And that was my
passion, languages.
My passion was also
to change the world,
like any liberal arts
Berkeley student can attest.
And so I traveled.
I studied abroad, as
I said, in Brazil.
I had great adventures.
That's actually called
[FOREIGN LANGUAGE], which
means-- you go to a church,
and then you grab one of those.
And then you tie it three times.
I have one right here.
And you make three wishes.
And when it falls
out, those wishes
are supposed to come true.
So I made those wishes.
I said, I want to
go to grad school.
I want to graduate without debt.
That was almost impossible,
but I almost made it there.
And I want to find
fulfilling career in my '20s.
I graduated Berkeley, and I
decided I wanted to give back.
Having my mom had had
cancer, I went ahead
and did a lot of health
education with women--
bi-lingual woman, women of
lower incomes and resources--
to make sure that I had
access to the right prevention
programs as well as treatment
programs for breast cancer.
But I decided I wanted to
go back to grad school.
And I did.
I went back to grad school.
I graduated in sociology
in Latin American studies.
I did my ethnography, my
research, in Northeast Brazil
on the concept of
street children.
And I talked about how in a
very Afro-Brazilian region,
and I just looked at
how race and class were
portrayed for urban youth.
You see youth here, that might
dress a different way, you
automatically classify them.
And this is done
throughout the world.
So I graduated with
very-- you know,
I wanted to work for UNICEF.
Wanted to move somewhere.
But then I came back
to the Bay Area.
And my mom, actually, was like,
now you need to get a job.
I did not come to this country
and raise you to be like,
oh, yes.
Let me travel some
more, and let me study.
She was like, you
need to get a job.
So I did a quick search.
I went on Craigslist,
and I just put "jobs,"
and then I just put "near me."
Palo Alto.
I found one in Palo Alto.
He's still my good friend.
He's a CEO.
[? David ?]
[? Conasomes ?] said,
you're too over-qualified
to be doing this job.
And I was like, I just need
to pay off some loans, please.
And that's my first startup.
The startup got acquired by
AKQA, the advertising agency.
That's how I ended up in tech,
by doing a quick search near me
on Craigslist.
That agency got
acquired by AKQA.
And before you know it,
I was off to London.
I was living in
London, setting up
the operations for
AKQA and [INAUDIBLE]
and having the time of my life.
Once again, decided to take
the opportunity to travel.
And if anyone here
is just-- traveling
just opens up your eyes,
I was always [INAUDIBLE],
like Latin America.
And then I went to Europe,
and I would go from London
and go to Prague or
go to Copenhagen.
And during that time my
recruiter calling like,
are you happy?
And I'm like, I'm
living in London.
Yay!
I am.
And they're like, how about
if you want to come back?
And I like, I should come
back to the United States.
And said, well, we're looking
for a contract position
at this company YouTube.
Have you heard of it?
This was in 2007.
I think it was a month or two
after it was acquired by Google
that I came onto the YouTube
family as a contractor.
That send me off to Brazil
because of my language skills.
And obviously my
language skills have
been a driving
force in my career.
And there at Google Brazil,
I met this beautiful, tall
German woman that
I first did not
like because she's so beautiful.
She was working at the
Google Hamburg office
and who's now one of my
best friends, [? Tompka. ?]
She lives in Mexico City.
She was actually, had been
with Google up until this year,
and then she became a mom
about I think 9 years.
And so [? Tompka, ?] and this
is a horizontal loyalty that I
speak about, [? Tompka ?]
never questions.
I say, maybe I don't
want to do this.
Or maybe I do.
Or maybe I want to open this.
And every time I see her, it
was like, what happened to that?
I was like, it didn't work out.
Or it did, but look.
And it's just never
questions, understands,
and she's like, whatever
you need from me.
Understands my talent.
Understands my drive.
Understands the
positions I want to make.
The 2008 was a hard time.
I don't know if a lot of you can
recall here in Silicon Valley.
There were layoffs,
left and right.
What I wanted was
just stability,
and I didn't feel like
startup world offered me that.
YouTube decided to
say, hey we were
going to bring this
position either in-country.
Do you want to go there or not?
And I said, not now.
I need to stay with my family.
I went to other several
startups, people that I've met.
They are still friends of mine.
One is a Google designer
here for Search.
I also have all these
friends that I worked--
that I met at all the startups
that we have followed.
But there were layoffs.
I got laid off,
[INAUDIBLE] to startup.
Then I was like, OK.
I'm laid off from this startup.
What do I do?
I went on Twitter.
At that time, when
another friend
of mine-- who's actually a
hacker here, Brad Fitzpatrick--
Brad's like, have
you heard of Twitter?
And I was like, why would I
want to post my breakfast?
Like no.
And he was like, you
should, you know.
And I joined.
And quickly, there was
a very basic design.
Five months later--
I call it mooning
because this is where
luck came in-- I saw this.
It was on the "Time Magazine."
And I was like, what are the
chances that I could apply?
I was already working
another startup,
so I had gotten a new
job through Twitter.
So I was working
another startup,
heading their Director of
Operations and Product.
And I became quickly more
addicted to this tool.
I read this, and I read about
the impact that Twitter had.
Read the profile of Biz and Ev.
At that point-- and I
think that's my phone.
It's my sister--
and they did not
have any positions open
that weren't infrastructure,
engineering.
Things like the reliability
and the [? failover ?]
at that time.
And then, I think they had
one position open for that.
And that position was a
contract position for someone
that spoke Spanish
and Portuguese.
So I was like, hmm, it's for me.
Let me apply.
I would have thought that
the sheer number of resumes
they probably got after being
on the cover of "Time Magazine"
and the Iran
Revolution probably--
don't know how my
resume stuck out.
At that point, the first
Twitter employee ever, Crystal,
calls me.
And Crystal hung up on
me after five minutes.
And I was like, I
just screwed that.
And then, when I asked
her later on when
I was hired why,
she was like, I knew
you were qualified
in five minutes.
And I knew this
would be, you know,
contract for [INAUDIBLE]
would take longer.
I took a severe pay cut.
I remember my
boyfriend at that time.
I went and got a manicure.
I was like, I think
this is the last time
I can get one that is nice
manicure because I just
took a pay cut to join this
company, who at that time
had just gotten hacked and
all of the internal memos
had been leaked.
There was a stability
with "Fail Whale."
The mainstream media
thought it was just
a tool to post
breakfast pictures.
There wasn't a
lot of credibility
to this over-hyped-- and
when sometimes I read things
around new products,
Snapchat and everything.
And the same criticisms
repeat themselves,
and you just know what the
value could be in the long run.
You wait and see on
what that happens.
And so I was hired.
I was the first Latina,
the first woman,
to join the international team.
I was one of the
founding team members.
The other woman was
[? Ukari, ?] who's
also an immigrant
from Japan who has
a similar story--
came as a child.
She was director of
international at that time,
and we launched.
I came in to launch
Twitter in espanol.
I was in Mexico for my
cousin's quinceanera
when we launched
Twitter in espanol.
And I was like, yay!
And everyone was
like, what is that?
We don't know what this tool is.
Even my mom-- like now, my
mom sees Mexican soap operas.
And she's like, oh, Twitter.
Yeah.
You have that.
So, yeah.
I came in doing
Twitter in espanol.
And it was really
amazing, because they just
pretty much-- Ev
and Biz were like,
do whatever you want with this.
And I was like, OK.
So it was like product,
[? BD, ?] support--
I was answering
tickets for people that
lost their passwords in Spanish.
Everything under the sun.
When you're an early
employee at a company,
you wear so many hats.
And anyone who was a startup
here understands your work.
I mean, you start up
within a bigger company.
I wear all these hats,
and they're like,
I've got full-time.
Six months later, team lead.
Two months later, manager.
Another six months later,
head of localization.
Things moved fast.
I tell people I think I was
40, but then-- the company's
all hands fit in one
couch at that point.
And the first all
hand that I-- it
was called Tea Time
that I attended--
was 3 and 1/2 hours on why
the "Fail Whale" was failing.
And so that's where
the adventure started.
And I say that was luck.
If I hadn't applied--
but it was my hard work
that got me into the
interview, into the door.
And it was the opportunity to
sell myself within the company.
I saw an opportunity
for localization
that international users--
when my team translated,
with the help of really
talented product, program
and engineering managers,
we launched right to left.
The impact that that had in the
Middle East, that was amazing.
So all of these
things are really
taking that opportunity
within that work to make sure
and chatting.
And during this time, I
created a lot of loyalties.
I would go as a
woman-- and I'm going
to say not having a
technical degree--
I would ask my
engineering managers,
when we were having a product
meeting, to repeat what I said
or to say it first
and I can agree, just
because I knew
that they would be
heard slightly
more than I would.
So [? Nico ?] and
Matt know that.
That I would be like, hey,
can you back me up on this?
I would say in a way, that
they didn't feel like they had.
But I think it was the
hidden rule between us--
that I had to go in there with
them so that I could be heard.
I don't think this is endemic to
just Twitter or to other ones.
And I don't think
it was a culture
within a certain organization.
I think it's just women
in tech in general.
My personality itself
is very outspoken,
so I want to be
heard the loudest.
Maybe it is because of who I
am, or maybe because of the fact
that I know that's the
only way I can get--
but you learn along the way.
Sometimes you learn
to not say anything
and to just understand.
And to also know that-- when I
was questioned by another woman
that I wasn't
technical enough, I
went and asked the engineer
managers on my end.
They're like, yes,
that it was technical.
Having built a whole tool
from going from scratch
of 1,200 volunteer translators,
crowd-sourcing translation
at Twitter to one million
by the time I left.
And having all of this
crowd-sourced languages
being translated--
simplified Chinese
was translating in
a day and a half--
by volunteer translators.
In Iran, when we
translate into Farsi,
translators actually
wrote [INAUDIBLE] says,
I cannot disclose
my actual identity,
or I could be imprisoned
or killed in Iran.
So given that impact
back and being inspired
by what I was doing, really I
didn't focus on the being woman
or being Latina.
I think I focused a little
bit more on the being Latina.
If I get called feisty too
many times, I will get feisty.
But that-- an
unconscious [INAUDIBLE].
Going back into what inspires
me, what makes me drive
is that we believed early on--
and I quote this to Biz Stone--
that we weren't just a
triumph of technology
and the triumph of humanity.
So like as you go
back, and you think how
your technology's-- going
back and making sure that that
triumph, that
technology's triumph.
But more importantly, how is
it helping humanity in general?
I'm going to put it out there.
Sometimes if I see
one more First World,
San Francisco-problem
startup fund--
I think like, this is great.
But you know where are those?
I knew about WhatsApp,
five, four years ago
because everyone uses that.
I use it to communicate with
my friends around the world.
And there are a lot of great
startups in Silicon Valley,
creating great products.
But they could also be, to a
certain extent, giving back.
And now I'm going to talk
about the loyalty component
and where this comes from
in the horizontal loyalty.
Robert Krulwich, and I
think I said it right,
is actually a journalist.
And he gave the commencement
speech at Berkeley in 2011
at the School of Journalism.
And he discusses this.
He discussed about thinking
about horizontal loyalty.
"Think about turning to
people you already know,
who are your friends, or
friends of their friends
and making something that
makes sense to you together--
both of you or all of you--
that is as beautiful or as true
as you can make it."
And that horizontal
loyalty is actually
what people can call networking.
I don't call it
networking, because I
don't go to network
events to meet people.
I go to connect people or
understand how I can help them.
I'm a mentor to several startups
from all over the world,
from Israel all the
way from Argentina.
And I tell them how can I open?
How can I make this connection?
How can I show you my loyalty?
Because I believe in your
product and your spirit
to be such an entrepreneur
that you're moving on.
A lot of entrepreneurs
come here,
and this is the region that's
paved of gold for them.
It's just they feel like
Sand Hill Road is, aah,
like the final point.
And the same, you know, if
you're an actor somewhere,
you think Hollywood is the same.
So I like just being
given that opportunities
and that horizontal loyalty.
I know several women.
And a friend of mine, I
interviewed her for a position
on my team.
Didn't get to hire her.
I added her on LinkedIn.
I said, I thought
you were amazing.
You were probably too badass
for us, and let's keep in touch.
And now she's one
of my close friends.
She's leading international,
very prominent firm,
and she talks to me about
her challenges as a new mom.
And so that loyalty that we
have together to make sure,
you know.
When I'm having
doubts professionally,
I don't think I have all
the answers in the world.
I turn to them, too, as
much as they turn to me.
And I've made mistakes,
many mistakes.
And so I tell them,
learn from my mistakes,
because I wouldn't want you
to go through those mistakes.
And those mistakes are the
politics at the office.
Or those mistakes as
not saying something
just because you feel passionate
without actually filtering
out, creating a filter that is
appropriate for that situation.
Or those mistakes that I feel
like I failed, and I turn
around and I understand
that each one of my failures
is actually a success
in the long run.
And there is a
quote that I always
say that success and
failure, treat them
with the same indifference,
meaning don't be too defined
by success.
When "Forbes" called
me and I was actually
moderating the Forbes panel
on the future of technology
in Mexico and I was in the
magazine, people were like,
how do you feel about
being so successful?
Or this or that.
And I said, you know what?
In 10, 15 years, you might
find me in a little magazine.
And I'll have a
little hut in Mexico,
putting up a restaurant.
And I'll be happy.
Probably that is my happiness,
to cook and live next
to the beach.
So don't define so much by the
success because it can go down;
it can go up.
And as well as a failure.
Define yourself by
how you handle both.
Definitely something that
I've learned along the way.
I put this flags
because I have friends
from all over the
world, men and women.
And I talk about the men that
have supported me and shown
horizontal loyalty
all over the world.
Everything from France, Israel.
My co-founder
building something,
he's actually
Palestinian-Canadian.
And [? Mo, ?] I met him
through the TechWomen Program.
TechWoman [? Ezra ?]
is from Egypt.
And when I advocated,
I was like, we
need to be part of TechWomen.
It was the most
amazing experience.
Now I'm going to select to
be part of that program.
The only person that
I want at Twitter
at that time to
make sure that we
were involved in
this amazing program.
And when [? Ezra ?]
came to me, I said,
[? Ezra, ?] you're
smarter than me.
I mean she runs
Research and Development
at Orange, a mobile company.
Engineer.
And I said, obviously you
know I can not teach you
anything on the
engineering front.
But what can I provide for you?
And she was like, I
want to be a startup.
I want to start a
startup one day.
And so say I said OK.
I'm going to give you meetings
with at least 30 people
around the company,
from business
to HR to marketing to market
development to engineering
to people operations
that you know.
So I display these
flags because--
and actually, you don't see
it because I have my boots.
But I have a tattoo that
I got of the world, long
before I came in here.
And everybody's like, you
really love the world.
Even on my phone case, I got
that as a Christmas present.
But it is.
It is the fact that, like
the horizontal loyalty
has shown throughout countries,
has shown throughout regions.
My friends in Brazil,
all my friends--
some of my closest
friends all live
in Monaco, Brazil,
Mexico City, Miami.
So it is that
horizontal loyalty.
And I always feel like
when I doubt myself,
I just see their little
flags and knowing
that they will cheer me on
regardless of the next step
happens.
Some people wait.
I don't.
I'm very impatient,
which is a bad thing.
But I'm trying to be a
little bit more patient.
There are just some
people that don't.
I am one of those people.
Like, you tell me
to kick the ball,
I kick it the farthest
and probably the fastest
than anyone can.
But it is.
Not waiting doesn't mean not
waiting for things to change.
And so I give back.
Some of my close friends are
MIT engineers, women, Latinas,
immigrants, that
are Latinas in STEM,
and so I drive to Central
Valley and help out
with whatever initiative
they have going.
So I don't wait in other
things that I want change.
Showing more women
in math and science
is definitely
creating that support
and stating, if
you're good at that,
maybe they will stick around.
I didn't, but I
still ended up here.
I'm working now a
job, [? when ?] I'm
sort of localizing the
internet of things.
It's a challenging position
to understand how technology
is going to relate to you as
a person, but not only to you
in your language in your locale.
The things are more personal
to you are those things.
If I decide to wear this around
my wrist or carry my phone,
that's-- you know, localization
isn't bad everywhere you see.
But you don't understand
that that's actually
very important to understanding
and your connection
to technology.
I also, as I said
[? Mo, ?] my co-founder,
I'm also want to at least
attempt at entrepreneurship.
This is some, the source
from "Mother Jones"
with a lot of the funding
that is being said.
And a lot of my
good, good friends
are [? VCs ?] and so nothing.
And I think that is
that shifting trend now
on what the demographics
are-- all males, 89%; mix, 8%;
an all-female founding
group is only 3%.
And then you have, of
course the race bias.
But I don't focus on as
much on the race, I think.
I focus on gender
because I believe
that, regardless of race,
women will put forward.
And you will see more
founders, more women.
I think there was a conference
around just female founders
recently.
This is a proverb that I
do-- and to my startup,
if you want to know, is
just about involving people
in technology in a way
through all the information
that we have available online.
And it's a Chinese proverb.
"Tell me and I'll forget;
show me and I may
remember; involve me
and I may understand."
So it's definitely key
to what's driving me,
my passion to build something
that will have people--
right now, we have a very
one-sided conversation
with technology or
within the internet.
And if you improve
people and involve them,
they will actually understand.
Finally, this is it.
I have had a lot of doubts
in my career, and in my life.
I'm really good friends
with all my ex-boyfriends,
and people are like,
how is that possible?
And I said they made me the
woman I am for whoever I date.
And so I think those are
my mistakes, whether-- they
weren't mistakes, but my
mistakes professional.
Don't tell them.
[LAUGHTER]
LAURA GOMEZ: They weren't, but
it's the same with the careers,
right?
I don't think I
compromise myself
on a personal/professional
matter.
And when I did and I felt
my integrity and who I am
as [? this ?]
[? essence ?] Laura.
I was compromised.
I've decided to get up.
It was hard to leave Twitter.
It was hard to leave other jobs.
It was hard to leave
this relationship,
but it was-- I didn't
compromise myself.
I didn't compromise
the deep Laura--
the essential,
authentic person I am.
I make compromises
every day into things,
not everything will fit me.
And not all things,
I will fit them.
So obviously there's
little compromise.
But the essential
compromise of yourself,
who you are, your identity as a
person and what you believe in.
And I talk to my
friends at Coursera,
and I think they're building the
greatest thing in the world--
accessibility to education.
I talk to Luis von Ahn who's
the founder of Duolingo.
He is just brilliant,
and the way
he's giving back
as far as language
learning, toppling down
all the institutions that
come with language learning and
making sure that you do that.
I see there's a lot of
people don't comprise
of [INAUDIBLE], that are still
passionate about technology
that they're putting
it back to that.
I feel that whatever
you do, whether you're
making a change your
life or in your product
or in the end result,
always just keep the center.
Don't compromise
[INAUDIBLE] yourself.
We are so lucky to live in
the land of opportunities.
And I was so lucky
that somehow the moon
decided to shift my mom and
my family into this region.
So here I am.
This is me, and I give
this thing to you.
Don't compromise.
I know because people
will follow you
throughout your whole life
and do the horizontal loyalty
if they know that
you are in tech
and that you're
true to yourself.
That's it thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
LAURA GOMEZ: I think I
have time for questions.
AUDIENCE: So in
your story, you talk
a lot about horizontal
loyalty and kind
of using these people in
your life to help your career
and help you keep going.
Do you have any tips on how
to find people like that?
Because I find as
a junior engineer,
I'm trying to
figure out how do I
position myself to
be in leadership?
What's the next step?
It's hard to find people
who are at that next step
to ask about those things.
LAURA GOMEZ: Yeah, yeah.
No, I think it's important
to either ask-- you know,
I asked myself a question when
I started off managing people
and then managing a group
of very large organization.
And the same questions
like, who can I help?
And a lot of people use a
mentor group, the mentorship.
But I use much more sort
of community of people.
Like if I'm having doubts in
a certain area, I go and ask.
And I think most people are
really friendly, especially
in here.
They're so willing to take
the time for that coffee
or take time for those things.
Or to keep in contact.
If it wasn't-- where is she?--
if it wasn't for Sabrina--
if it wasn't for Sabrina who
heard my talk a couple of years
ago, I wouldn't be here.
And so there are those
times where you actually
want to make those connections
and or like follow up
with people.
I think like as a
junior engineer,
you don't probably
necessarily need
to talk to another woman
engineer or more female.
You could talk to someone
that has that leadership, that
experience on how to
handle career growth.
Not necessarily--
like we always look,
I was like can I find
a Latina in tech.
And can she be my mentor?
No, my mentors have been all
shapes and sizes, all colors
and all genders, in different
stages of my career.
So you don't have to
just look, you know.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
You've been a part
of a lot of companies
that paved the way for tech.
Coming from a
non-technical background,
how did you bridge
that gap in leading
the way in these high
profile tech companies,
coming from a
non-technical background?
LAURA GOMEZ: What I had
for me was my language,
was my ambition--
not ambition, drive.
Because ambition means
you compare yourself
to somebody else.
But I had an internal drive.
I had my intelligence, my
experience, my background.
And my passion.
Like time and time again, if I
hear about more person describe
me as passionate,
I will be like, OK.
Yes.
It was that.
It was that my commitment
to learn, be a fast learner
and to think and to make sure
that I was able to demonstrate
the business needs, the product
needs and implement that.
And I think coming from a
non-technical background
shouldn't inhibit
any of your pursuit--
I know a lot of
product managers.
I know-- for
example, even people
with technical background.
I was at [? Square ?]
the other day,
just chatting with some people.
And they told me a story
about an engineer that
was an industrial
mechanical engineer that
wanted to be a
software engineer.
And so he took
courses with Coursera
and got a job now doing software
engineering at [? Square. ?]
So I think it's not even the
technical background, where
you want to be headed.
It
There is such a
diversity on [? back-- ?]
but in such a diversity
in technology right now,
but it's much more about
what are your assets?
What are your strengths
that you can show early on?
Languages for me was that door
opening and taking that door
into technology.
So that was for me.
I don't know what it
is for you, but you
might want to just look at
where those strengths are.
And there's also not
working on the tech.
You can do product marketing.
Marketing, there's just so rich.
I started off in the ad
operations sales organization
and made my way more
into the product
because that's where
my passion lied.
Not necessarily in the
coding but much more shaping
the product, the
international product.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
LAURA GOMEZ: Hi.
AUDIENCE: I just
wanted to thank you
for quoting Zora Neale Hurston.
That was a really powerful
and controversial quote.
And I wanted to know, what
else can we discuss or can
we think about black women's
position, and Latino women's
position, in the tech field.
And even thinking
about this conference
and the very few numbers
of black women here today.
What can we do as a
community of women
to support those
who we don't see?
LAURA GOMEZ: So I
think the one problem,
and I'm not thinking
it's this, is
that I know a lot of
black tech groups.
I know a lot of
Hispanic tech groups.
They're all still fragmented.
And I believe if we
would just come together
into-- this is why I was real
excited about this event.
I was like, this
is the one event
that I'm not seeing the same
people over and over again.
And I love all my Latinos
in tech and Hispanic.
But obviously, I see
them more than my mom.
It's just like coming in
and meeting new people,
meeting new faces.
The young women that
were sitting at my table
while we were doing the
prototyping were so exciting,
and it was just
like going outside.
And I think seeing
that and inviting more.
I was honored to be here
and to speak of my story,
but not really focused in that.
And then just making sure
that it's not just-- we
isolate ourselves.
This is about just diversity
in general in tech.
You see a lot of prominent
women in technology,
discussing their stories.
I have a friend that's an
African American woman that
said, that's a great story.
But that's not my story.
But it still, it's a story
around a certain thing.
So just talking about diversity
and not making-- sure,
I've made jokes at the end
of meetings where like, oh,
I'm the only girl here.
Or I'm the only woman here,
just so that people can open up
and talking about just
diversity in general.
And making sure that as girls
are learning how to code,
also the girls that may
not have had that support
to learn how to code
have access to being
in this amazing industry that is
changing, literally, the world.
And we get to live here.
And I that's where the
moon comes into my life.
Anything else?
Great.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
SOWMYA SUBRAMANIAN:
Thanks, Laura.
It was great hearing your story.
We were chatting a little
bit before the talk started,
and it was just really great.
Thank you.
All right.
So before we move
to the next session,
we'll take a 10 minute break.
And please check what the other
talk you want to go to is.
And if you want to go
to the different room,
there are volunteers in the
back with the [? cute ?] card
that you can follow.
And then we meet back here in
10 minutes, for the next talk.
[MUSIC - THE MANHATTANS -
"SHINING STAR"]